Tales Over Rice, the
25th anniversary title of the Tales of series.  The
passion of passion can quickly surpass itself.I want
to deliver the flame that the Pale Zorb series has kindled to more people in a wider area.  Will a lot of people be able to
feel that passion?
To do that, we would need to go on quite an adventure as we
proceeded with development.  I
thought that I needed art that would allow me to be more deeply immersed in the story I was spinning.me The only person who could make that happen was Mr. Iwamoto, who has been involved in the art direction and character design of past titles.
In order to inherit the drawing style that everyone in the series is attractive to and keep it up-to-date, I
thought about the points of a sense of unity and a sense of reality where the characters and the world are actually together.  I've
been thinking a lot about the problems of existence, the lives and positions of the
characters, whether they're incompetent when they fight, or whether they'll see the sounds they make when they open up to their friends.  This
kind of expression harmonizes even the breathing of the characters. To achieve this, we
developed the Oshimasu shader.
Seida is one of those adjustments.I
spent 5 years developing and improving it.To
accommodate 3 times that, I'm
trying to make the facial expressions of the characters have a sense of unity.
It
can't beat the superficial appearance of the product.It's being
realized in the whole academic field.Of
course, we
will continue to convey the thoughts of the succession and evolution that Melzo Barrise is aiming for from various perspectives.Please
look forward to the release.
[music]